- So Lee Ann, how many
kittens do you have?
How many cats do you have?
- Over forty now.
- Over forty.
- How many years have you been down here?
- Oh, probably over 20.
- Okay. Tell me about your childhood.
You grew up where?
- New Mexico.
- What city?
- Bloomfield right, right.
About 40 miles South of Durango, Colorado.
- And eh, you grew up
with both your parents?
- Huh?
- Did you grow up with both your parents?
- No. My mother had me,
so she'd get a check.
My father was in the service
And she can eat it up and drink it up.
And she tried to bait him so
that he would take the bait
And get killed and he
didn't take the bait.
He took off, but her second
husband took the bait
And she got him killed and got some money.
He thought she'd go and get
the rest of the day she died,
but took her away.
Or she sang her song cause
she just kept up evil plot.
She invited me to see her.
I hardly, I never stayed with her.
And she nearly got my
grandma in the prison.
Cause my grandmother took us and ran off
Without her permission.
And she got to get me
on the Thorazine chip.
I was only 15 years old.
She brought Thorazine
and said it was vitamins
And she'd go to clinic, check
on me the rest of my life.
And so she got my grandmother
And the court kidnapping
charges and she saw the judge
And Aztec
And the court reporter was the wife
Of my grandmother's husband's boss.
And he told, she told
the judge what happened.
And the judge ruled my
grandma's other way.
Why she'd been in prison
The rest of her life, trying to save us?
- How, how was your childhood?
- Huh?
- How was your childhood?
- Oh, it was bad.
I'm telling you
- Do you have children?
- Huh?
Do you have children?
- Yeah. I'm the mother of six children
each by a different man.
That's how I know that there's ism jazz.
And as Christian jazz
does not get it and ah...
- Did you raise your kids?
- Huh? No, I was consensual sex sorta.
When I got pregnant each time one man
I did say to him and didn't
want to hurt his feelings.
- Did you raise your children?
- Huh?
- No, I kept Melissa a year.
Then we thought psych
drugs and like vitamins.
So I swallowed the first Stella.
They didn't stop my
pain and boy, I was, it
Mine was proven good.
I called my grandma.
Couldn't get my children can
figure out what, what to do.
And I become convinced that
I would get feeling good
If I took some psych drugs,
everybody was doing that
And thought they were
like, vitamins must have.
And I ended up in hideous
pain from swelling, Thorazine
And it took me three
months to walk it off.
I walked back for the
burden and hideous pain
And by then my brain was damaged so bad.
I could not, she had
not told the next time.
- All right Lee Ann.
Well, thank you so much for talking to me.
- Okay.
And good luck with the
- Yeah. I got to get breakfast down
And go ask the many cats and
try and get up enough money
to pay the extra storage
we're getting over here
cause, or they'll throw
my stuff out of my room.
Right after I'd already
been attacked in their bad.
And I got attacked the
camp and I ended up with BD
And got treated for, I
was go to try to make it
To Hollywood where I get BD.
Now I get real.
Um I get real weak.
And I was sitting over in
front of the police station.
I'm getting ready to try
to make it totally went
To the hospital emergency.
- So, how are you getting BD from a...?
- Somebody raped me.
I don't know.
They, they, they liked to rape me
Cause I'm short they didn't both middle
He was like dog,
especially if you're short
And cause they figure
that have a real night to.
Oh man they slammed me
against heavy objects down.
They got me the other night.
I thought I tried to chain
myself up in their favor
and didn't get it good
enough so they slammed me...